hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the middle of
meditation 6 Rene Descartes engages in a
little bit of discussion on the human
faculties and he's not attempting to
provide a comprehensive survey but he is
setting out some important
characteristics of the faculties of the
human mind and now at this point most
importantly not just the human mind but
also the human body so the human being
as a totality composed of two different
substances United in some as yet to be
explained way namely a thinking
substance that of the human mind and a
extended or a corporeal substance that
of the human body and there's the a
juncture between them and you can say
that certain of the faculties you might
say straddle the the two of these they
don't do so in exactly the same way so
that they're present in the mind in the
same way that they're present in the
body that would be impossible given the
nature of the mind and the nature of the
body one of which is divisible the other
which is not divisible one of which is
extended the other which is not extended
not material does not exist in space and
time but there are some
the faculties that you could say not
only make reference to something outside
of the human mind but actually involve
the human body and even more so involve
the human body in a world of other
bodies a world of extended substances
which act upon each other so he says and
this is uh about halfway through the
sixth meditation I find in myself
particular very particular faculties of
thinking which are distinct from me that
is the faculties of imagining and of
sensation
imagine a a sont here in French right
without which I would be able to
conceive myself clearly and distinctly
as a whole to taunt the air but not
those without me that is without a
intelligent substance to which they are
attached and he goes on he says the
notion that we have of these faculties
or their their formal concept in that
they they include some sort of
intellection from which i conceive that
they are distinct from me just like
figures and movements and other modes or
accidents of bodies are from the bodies
themselves which maintained or underlie
them su Tian right and so as opposed to
say the faculties that are more purely
of the human mind like intellection or
conception the work of the understanding
the untundi MA in French or that a
volition which by this point in the
meditations we've seen encompasses an
awful lot not just selection but also
affirming denying you know engaging in
judgments pursuing and avoiding engaging
in practical decision-making in action
which also includes judgments and then
we might also include the Faculty of
memory although we have to be a little
be careful with that right because their
Faculty of memory includes not only
purely intellectual things like
remembering the coach ito or remembering
the arguments that that decart is
provided in this but it also includes a
lot of things coming from sensation and
so memory is a little bit of a hybrid
compared to volition and intellection
but even those you could say
intellection is oftentimes going to be
of things that we are imagining or
sensing we're grasping the true and
immutable natures of them as we saw in
meditation five volition is another
thing which extends outward into the
world of our body and other bodies so we
could say that there's something as well
of that but we can conceive of this
stuff over here without bringing in the
body as decart did in the earlier
meditations when he stripped away the
body when he stripped away the entire
universe by means of the hyperbolic
doubt not so with imagination and
sensation and so he goes on and he says
here we go we also have other we also
have other faculties he says like those
of changing place or of putting
ourselves into multiple positions or
postures right and other similar things
which cannot be conceived he says any
more than the preceding ones and the
preceding ones are imagination
and sensation without some substance to
which they would be attached and
therefore by consequence cannot exist
without them then he goes on he says but
it's very evident that these faculties
if it's true that they exist must be
attached to some corporeal or extended
substance and not to a intelligent
substance why because in their clear and
distinct concept there is some sort of
tension which is found included in that
but not at all that of intelligence so
you know all these things that have to
do with what we do with our body you
know changing place moving from one spot
to another locomotion as we say we might
also think about the things within our
body like the Faculty of digestion right
or you know things like that all of
those really pertain just to the body
now you might say volition could play a
role in that right we move from one
place to the other because we decide to
do that right inside my intelligence or
understanding and my intellect there's
some sort of process that's going on
that says hey move that body of yours
from one place to another but the actual
Faculty of locomotion is just there in
the body it's part of that extended
substance and it has to do if you think
about it and it doesn't just refer just
to the body it refers to the body within
a field of other bodies I can only move
in space provided that there actually is
space right I move from one place to
another you recognize my moving across
the field of this chalkboard precisely
because you see me changing place
relative to this thing that stays still
and similarly putting oneself in
positions crossing my arms you know
putting my hands on my head
all of those sorts of things again we're
doing that within space you might even
say within time as well and in relation
to other bodies so let's go on a little
bit more with this this passage he says
that in addition to this I also
recognize in myself this certain passive
Faculty of sensation that is to say
receiving and knowing ideas of things
that are sensible things that I can
perceive with my senses
and he says but this would be not useful
to me if I could if I was not able to
make use of it so there is inside of me
or in something else some other active
faculty capable of forming and producing
ideas now what is that active faculty we
could look at that as sort of the active
side of sensation but you might also
call that the Faculty of imagination
right imagination is an active and
powerful Faculty it's one that
oftentimes Descartes things leads us
astray because we rely on it too much
instead of intellection as we've seen
him talk about earlier in the work so he
says that here we go this active faculty
could not be in me insofar as I was not
something that thinks given that it you
know does not presuppose my thought and
these are also that these ideas are not
these ideas are often represented
without me contributing in any way and
often against my desire against my my
will you could say that's the the
sensation part and he says therefore
necessarily it must be in some substance
different than me in which all the
reality which is objectively contained
in those ideas that are produced is
contained formally or eminently as I've
remarked before meditation 3 right and
that substance is either a body that is
to say corporeal nature a nature right
or in which would be contained formally
or and in effect everything that's
objectively and by representation and
the ideas or it would be God itself or
some other creature more noble than the
body in which that would be contained
eminently and he rejects that idea
actually some other Cartesians would
take up that idea later on but Descartes
says no no that's not the case what I'm
grasping
through sensation and then working on
through imagination is coming to me by
the body there is a faculty within the
body that is able to take in rather
several faculties able to take in
information from the outside world and
those those ideas that we have in the
mind afterwards which have objective
reality correspond to things that have
formal reality or eminent reality if we
want to buy into that notion in the
things themselves of the world that
we're perceiving which could be in fact
our own body some of the things that
we're perceiving are indeed our own
hands or if we're looking in a mirror
our head I suppose we can perceive our
head by putting our hands on it or we
can feel the sensations in it all right
thank you you can knock on your head and
hear the sensation of that as well I
suppose
when you're listening to your own voice
you're also hearing your head in a
certain way as well as your windpipe and
lungs and things like that right so some
of the sensations could be of your own
body and some of them would be of the
outside world there'd be a faculty
within us and then over on the side of
the mind we would have the objective
reality ideas the representations of
those sensations within the human mind
so that sensation and imagination in as
I said earlier sort of straddle the
thinking substance and the extended
substance not that they're the same in
both substances but they would involve
both substances and in a certain way
they are less essential to the human
mind
you